excusez-moi un documentaire pour brut
désolé je train de bouffer est-ce que
vous accepterz d'être privé de tous vos
écrans pendant tout un mois téléphone
tablette ordinateur zé écran même pas le
téléphone vos écrans i s télé ser pour
[Musique]
vous en de faire une
story
qu'on nous enlève tous les écrans tous
les écrans ouis c'est un peu dur
compliquéème c'est mon job c'est il
dépend beaucoup des écrans dans le je
vidéo ça va être chaud quand même bah on
a une vie sur les réseaux sociaux faut
la gérer quoi excuse-moi
bonjour excusez-moi bonjour est-ce que
je peux vous embêter de petites secondes
vraiment j'ai du mal à trouver des gens
si vous pouvez m'aider ouais
ou imaginez que là je vous dis fait une
exp sans le téléphone comment pas de
téléphone pendant un
mois en fait moi c'est Taric et je dois
vous faire un aveu je suis pas mieux que
vous bah ouais moi aussi je suis accro à
mes écrans pour jouer danser draguer me
marrer mat des séries transpirer bosser
j'y passe des heures et des heures je
swipe je scroll je
like j'ai toujours les yeux rivés sur
cet écran com il passe de ma main à ma
poche ou de ma poche à ma
main la pire angoisse plus de réseau
j'avoue je suis un peu accro à tout ce
qui est Instagram tout ça je pense qu'on
est la génération la plus amè d'être
accro moi je m'en fous de ce que les
gens ils pensent en général et toi ma
musique est sur mon téléphone les photos
sur le téléphone le matin je me lève
minimum 1h30 à 2h avant que je parte
juste pour pouvoir regarder ta série
juste pour pouvoir regarder ma
série combien d'heur est-ce que vous
passez sur vos écrans chaque
jourviron 10h tu regard sur les éc anim
des
vidéos jeux
pas ma journée sur mon téléphone sur mon
iPad sans arrêt et des fois j'oublie de
manger
[Musique]
et on coup tout pas une température avec
laquelle on peut
négocierendant
moabeth je que je su pas le se juste
pour
voir j'ai trouvé mes premiers cowbo
c'est en couple de jeun retraité il
s'appelle Catherine et Vincent ils ont
65 et 67 ans moi il m'agace de passer
trop de temps sur Facebook et je suppose
que je l'agace à jouer à mes truc idiot
pendant des heures
voilà je viens d'avoir un coup de
pression de mon rédacteur en chef
c'estdi là il me dit les seigneurs c'est
super mais c'est pas totalement la cible
de brut en vrai il a pas tout à fait
tort bon là ça sent pas très bon parce
qu'il y a personne
ouais genre un mois sans écran ça ça
vous tenterait non pourquoi on fait tout
avec on va pour les cours pour les
devoirs pour du temps c'est impossible
c'est impossible
ou un moi sans écran les gars ça vous
dit un mois sans
écran la meilleure
celle
[Musique]
Mo Albert un mois sans écran tu
sign non un mois c'est quand même très
long il y a un truc que je voulais voir
avec toi parce qu'en fait j'arrive pas à
trouver de jeunes ça veut dire forcément
que l'addiction elle est plus forte chez
chez chez eux c'est pas de
l'addiction si je sais pas je suis à la
retraite ou si j'ai ma vie de couple ou
j'ai mes potes et cetera et cetera on a
déjà construit quelque chose alors que
quand on est encore jeune euh c'est une
partie intégrante et puis je pense
qu'aussi il y a ce rapport de un enfant
ne contrôle pas encore ou un ado même ne
contrôle pas encore si on s'entend de
téléphone il est encore puni on le prime
de son téléphone et il y a tout ce que
ça représente de pourquoi est-ce que je
vais m'autopunir ouais tout seul
excusez-moi les gars je peux vous parler
deux trois petites minutes s'il vous
plaît c'est un truc pour brut on est
enain de jouer là je pourrais pas je
pourrais pas ah ouais en fait c'est
quand même un moyen de s'évader enfin
les les téléphones les réseaux moi je
sais que je pourrais VO ouais quand tu
me demandes est-ce que je suis prêt de
signer un mois sans écran en fait la
question implicite c'est est-ce que tu
tu es prêt signé un mois sans internet
et avec l'utilisation que j'ai
d'internet c'est un mois sans
potentiellement des choses
professionnelles sans une partie de ma
vie sociale sans plein de corellair où
l'écran est juste un moyen et donc après
si c'est pour une expérience évidemment
peut-être que je diraiis oui mais mais
en fait c'est
non bon je vous apporte des nouvelles on
a un couple cher et yaba ils ont tous
les deux 28 ans ils sont super je sens
que ça va le faire je suis un fan
d'Instagram en vrai il a mes petits
chats au calme les écrans du coup ça
occupe bah beaucoup beaucoup de
place on vient tout juste de nous
enlever notre télé donc je me dis
euh ça sera un silence comme ça pendant
un mois
ce silence
[Musique]
là
a défaut d'avoir une télé on
[Musique]
va on va mettre le TR
[Applaudissements]
disque on a réussi on a réussi on a
réussi sans tuto
YouTube trop musique ouais c'était comme
ça les Viny
et on va aller acheter d'autres
albums TR
musique se filme avec quoi avec une
petite caméra je leur donné une petite
caméra à tous c téléphone on les
remplace je vous donne on c'est sympa
non c'est bien il y a pas d'armaque
comment ça il faut appuyer làhaut j' sur
côté je crois ou et quand c'est éclairé
on voit rien ça va nous occuper un
moment ça c'est bien là on tape dans le
lourd
non non ça ça sert à rien du tout parce
que on a dit à tout le monde qu'on
pouvit envoyer des SMS c'est même pas
[Musique]
vrai de
l'art
c'est le prix qui
t'as ou c'est le
poids ah Seigneur
Dieu oh Seigneur il est pas donné de
quoi il est pas donné ad ça c'est ça
c'est 4 mois
d'abonnemento oh
là moi je cherche un rayon pour les
[Musique]
pauvres
je pensais pas que c'était ça écouter la
vie musicale sans les
[Musique]
écrans un mois sans écran avec les plus
jeunes bah j'ai j'ai pris que des murs
pourtant j'ai rien
lâché si j'ai dû finir par lâcher j'ai
négocié longuement avec deux sœurs pas
facile en affaire et on a Dilé une
semaine sans
écran on
recommence bref je recencer du coup en
fait là c juste pour vous dire que
pendant toute la semaine en fait j'aurai
pas mon téléphone du coup en fait
j'auris un autre téléphone je suis en
train de écrire les numéros de mes
contacts comme ça même si j'ai pas snap
même si j'ai pas insta même si j'ai pas
Twitter j'ai les numéro en fait c'est
carré oh comment on fait pour regarder
pour regarder tu sur le petit bouton
play on est avec l'équipe de brut on est
ensemble je rig je
rigole je m'appelle Lina et j'ai 10 ans
je m'appelle Iness et j'ai 15 ans moi je
suis sur snap insta TikTok Netflix
YouTube est-ce qu'on peut écouter de la
musique avec ça non m pas en rêve la
dernière fois je me rappelle j'avais
cassé mon téléphone
et du coup j'avais pleuré elle avait
pleuré toutes ses larmes parce que j'ai
plus mon téléphone je récupère
ça et la télé vasy moi je regarde pas
moi du coup je regarde ordinateur je
regarde les
téléréalités ça en fait des écrans là
sur la play je joue à GTA Spider-Man et
à FIFA Spiderman c'est mon jeu je joue
quand
[Musique]
même
h toi c'était quoi déjà ce petit écran
que tu aimes
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup j'ai ma switch avec moi je
voyage pas sur ma switch tu veux lui
dire un dernier mot je
[Musique]
t'aime là vous allez faire une semaine
avec zéro écran il y a quoi à la maison
pour s'occuper quand il y a pas d'écran
des jeux de société et des livres et et
des livres
elle va plutôt aller à
francprieelle pourquoi parce qu'elle va
tout le temps acheter des bonbons
ell elles sont nées dans un monde avec
écran ils sont ils ont ses habitudes
donc déjà chapeau pour elle d'avoir
accepté mais tu vois une semaine sans
écran c'est c'est ce qui se fait dans
des écoles en France un peu partout ça
ça ça peut apporter quoi comme bénéfice
bouger son corps discuter avec d'autres
personnes explorer le monde extérieur et
cetera c'est important un des problèmes
majeurs qu'on identifie dans les
recherches sur l'utilisation des écrans
c'est que l'écran nous pousse à être
sédentaire et ça c'est un un problème
pour les enfants c'est encore plus grave
et plus problématique
v-y
matin
coucou on va essayer les
domino d'habitude le matin je joue la
S que je mange
toujours j'ai toujours rien à
faire
attendez c'est compliqué une caméra du
coup ce matin quand je me suis levé ben
en fait j'ai utilisé le réveil
tranquille pour une fois comme j'ai pas
de téléphone je me suis levée archit tôt
genre 7h pile j'étais debout et je suis
sortie grave en avance parce que d'abud
j'arrive toujours en retard mais là
cétait
super là je vois pas et je vais voir ma
copine j'espère qu'elle va pas me parler
de téléphone comme elle a droit si elle
me parle des nouvelles t TikTok je vais
craquer non je
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
rigole regardez là c'est très serré
parce que là moi je les ai tous il
manque juste le ha 67 et elle 65 ha et
il reste juste ça comme B là i 23 va pas
j'ai gagné j'ai gagné mais il est quelle
heure m moi je dis je suis fatigué ah
oui
21h25 bonne
nuit jeange pas
allez franchement aujourd'hui j'étais
perdu genre sur mon téléphone genre
j'avais aucun repère dem une nouvelle
journée
oui donc sur ce on leur dit bonne nuit
je parle là on leur dit bonne nuit
bon
B est-ce que il y a vraiment des effets
particuliers enfin propre aux
adolescents qui viennent des écrans oui
chez les ados il y a pas mal de
recherches qui montrent des effets
néfastes sur plein de choses la première
une étude qui est sortie récemment c'est
sur l'image de de soi de son corps chez
les jeunes filles ad particul
particulièrement adolesente à cause
d'Instagram parce que toutes les photos
sont retouchées une photo est prise
100000 fois avant décider laquelle on va
poster alors que moi je me regarde dans
le miroir j'ai un retour pas pas
airbroché ni rien du tout il y a des des
impacts négatif aussi parce que quand je
suis sur un écran et je suis un ado ça
veut dire que je suis pas par exemple en
train de faire de l'activité physique
donc ça a des comorbidités même sur le
fonctionnement du corps pas juste de la
santé mentale les enfants non parlons
même pas les enfants genre en dessous de
6 ans et cetera là c'est pas bien du
tout parce que on est en train de
comprendre les codes sociaux là on se
parle on se regarde dans les yeux et
cetera et si je parle avec ma fille elle
est tout le temps sur son téléphone mais
il y a tous les jeux de regard plein de
trucsou va croire que c'est normal de
s'adresser à un surtout il y a des des
choses qu'il faut apprendre et qui sont
très compliqués à
[Musique]
intégrer
allô tu vois hier comme tu m'avais dit
oui pour le
maquillage il me reste 52 minutes devant
moi est-ce que je peux faire mais avec
la la
caméra on m'a dit oui pour essayer de me
maquiller on va
dire qu'est-ce que je vais faire
il d de voir un tuto sur Youtube ce que
fait
c'est
[Musique]
moche c'est quelque chose mon mari est
en
dépression je pense qu'il repense à sa
vie je ressens des trucs mais je sais
pas encore quoi je sais que il y a
quelque chose qui se passe dans mon cœur
mais je ressens un vite en fait je
ressens un vite je ressens un vite
clair en plus j'ai même plus Instagram
ni rien en fait ça fait trop c'est trop
j'ai pas signé pour ça moi à la base
j'ai pas signé pour ça déjà à la base
j'ai pas
signé déjà comment ils nous ont contacté
vous ils sont passés par ta maman non
mais comment ils ont contacté ma maman
la télé prend beaucoup de temps parce
que personnellement j'ai pas assez de
temps mais la télé prend le peu de temps
que j'ai avec mes enfants
[Musique]
venez du Sénégal c'est ça oui je viens
du
[Musique]
Sénégal
Ron é ton téléphone s'il te
[Musique]
plaît des
assiettes il y a des couples que même
sur le lit ils ont chacun son téléphone
làdessus c'est pourut c'est pour ça qu'
faut mettre des règles oui mais a des
moments tu es sur le téléphone sans
savoir même pourquoi tu es sur le
téléphone vous avez quel souvenir de
privé de
télé très contente de quitter la télé et
profiter de mes enfants quoi mis des
bougies et j'avais amené un joueur de
cor moi l'expérience que j'avais de ça
c'est un film d'horreur pour moi au
départ France j'avais rien demandé du
tout après moi dans la vidéo quand je
vois ma mère elle était
contente tu es contente de faire cette
émission don maintenant se retrouver
dans le salon à devoir communiquer c'est
ça je retrouve ça un peu dans
l'expérience d'aujourd'hui là par
exemple c'est comme des trucs où quand
on est au téléphone des fois ou même
Instagram tu sais des fois je vois tes
story tes trucs donc je sais un peu ce
que tu fais donc je vais pas forcément
prendre des nouvelles or que des quand
là il y a pas d'écran il y a des gens je
me rend compte tu les vois pas du tout
donc tu je me sens des fois même appelé
ouais comment ça va ça juste pour avoir
le contact et m'assurer que ça va ce qui
est dangereux c'est que à force de voir
euh les réseaux sur les groupes WhatsApp
et tout ça là tu as l'impression de
vivre une réalité qui n'est pas du tout
réelle tu vois et si tu es une personne
comme moi qui aime voir les êtres
humains les toucher il y a quelque chose
qui manque en tant que en tant qu'être
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
humain on pas aller regarder la
télévision est aller regarder le match
oui on regarder oui d'accord CIT la
télévision tout
même on est allé chez des amis regarder
la
télévision quand on va au
éc faire un truc c'est qume différent
que
d'allumer la télé façon un peu mécanique
parce que c'est
20 qui ça tomba bien l'intention de
regarder
match le match qui va commencer c'est
parti le coup BO qui est donnéut stir il
faut sortir le
cartonou qui va jouer sur marquinos qui
a une relance un petit peu comment on
dit approximative quelques
instant c'est un truc de ouf alors qu'
il y a rien là on
peut m syva qui va s'écarter sur le côté
c'est pour la
de la de
Chr ça fait encore plus
mal VO
pasuxour
tonm sonti parce que là je suis encore
plus énervé par que je dis
[Musique]
pour la tte
de
[Musique]
m j'ai
espér tu vois le
gars il
[Musique]
don c'est valide ou
[Applaudissements]
pas en
de à pour le paris-germain la tête deald
ouais mais dans quelle circonstance ils
ont
marqué F et c'est la mi-temps le
parisgermain qui en fait pour de vrai je
sens que mon cerveau il travaille genre
là je suis
fatigué j'ai trop réfléchi tu
vois bon parce que j'ai réfléchi la
journée mais là je normalement tu viens
tu consommes tu vois là tu es en mode je
comprends pas je ne comprends pas
comment c vasy donnez-moi les infos
tu d'habitude il a une information
multisensoriel dans le sens plus que un
sensécran j'ai
toutécran le timing les numéros des
joueurs ù la B en fait on lui a é un
sens ces effets de contraste c'est ça
qui qui font cet effort de merde j'ai
pas l'information que j'ai d'habitude il
faut que je me concentre beaucoup plus
pour pouvoir recompléter l'image que je
suis en train
d'avoir parti et c'est le l'égalisation
[Applaudissements]
du de but partout PSG qui nbre d'asion
va mett c'est mie mett la
[Musique]
musique
il fait bon aujourd'hui il fait beau
donc j'en ai profité pour faire une
petite
marche j'aime bien me poser mes
questions existentielles faire ma petite
introspection et tout ce temps là sans
écran
bah ça m'aide
à ça m'aide à à définir ce que j'aime
vraiment ce qui m'anime ce qui me fait
vibrer un peu [__] sur sur ma mission de
vie quoi pourquoi je suis là ça me
permet d'avoir plus cette disponibilité
mentale pour bosser dessus
et et je le sens bien je le sens bien je
vais essayer de
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
créer aujourd'hui fait un peu
froid direction le travail
direction
quand je suis dans le métro je m'entends
penser et c'est constant je m'entends je
m'entends je m'entends je parle je
discute après j'ai des choses
intéressantes qui
sortaient du genre je me suis demandé
pourquoi les sièges du métro ils étaient
bleus pourquoi du coup il y a un petit
fil si c'est est-ce que c'est utile ou
est-ce que c'est juste de la décoration
pourquoi le bleu est-ce que le bleu
c'est une longueur d'onde qui nous fait
plaisir ou pas bref beaucoup beaucoup de
réflexion je regarde les gens j'imagine
le qu'est-ce qu'ils font avant de venir
ça se trouve lui va rentrer
écriv ça trouve l'autre il est triste
parce
queve cré des
histoires ouais non mais clairement je
suis dans un bah faut combler le vide he
fais super ou ouais c'est si on me donne
pas de on me donne pas d'écran me donne
pas d'image il faut que je me les
invente tu vois
sinon globalement en général c'est bien
d'avoir des temps comme ça où il y a il
y a des bénéfices sur les temps morts il
y a même un réseau dans le cerveau qui
s'appelle le mode de réseau par défaut
ouis c'est en fait un état dans notre
cerveau qui s'active quand on ne fait
rien
on n'est pas dans le moment présent on
n'est pas en train de méditer on est on
est on zone h et on s'entend parler des
fois on s on discute avec soi-même on
appelle ça les métacognitions la petite
voix avec laquelle je parle pour évaluer
les pensées automatiques qui viennent
les émotions automatiques qui viennent
et ça peut faire des des tas de trucs
qui semblent être assez bénéfique et
c'est pas une bonne idée du moment où
j'ouvre mes mes yeux jusqu'à ce que je
me couche que l'attention soit tout le
temps sollicitée par par des trucs que
ça soit le travail les écrans mes
enfants
tout je sais pas si ça
[Musique]
marche tuux je passe
devant tu vas voir bouge pas bouge
pas je sais pas ce que ça fait du tout
mais
bon bouge pas c'est justement
derrière vous êtes partis quelques jours
à saintnazer sans écran oui ça ça a été
il faisait beau il y a la mer c'est ça
par certains aspects on s'en passe très
bien on l'avit déjà vécu il y a 35 ans
on jamais vécu comme un traumatisme
cette affaire en
revanche pour moi c'est la question des
automatismes ça va ça va très vite quand
la télé sera revenue ici je pense que
nous reprendrons d'une certaine façon un
rythme parce que que le poid culturel
est là
je
voilà j'ai écrit lundi 29 novembre 22h32
je rerange ma chambre pour pas que je
m'ennuie 22h35 j'ai fini il y avait rien
à ranger à part mon tapis 22h36 je
m'ennuie après je dessiné un
ors 22h55 je suis sur mon lit et je
regarde le plafond
22h30 je lis un livre pour pas que je
m'ennuie le livre c'est ça
95 pages et j'ai
lu
ça j'ai lu ça
ensite je me suis endormie et j'ai pas
lu plus c'est
tout notre perception du temps est
quelque chose qui est très malléable
selon comment on dépense notre attention
si je suis dans une discussion
passionnée avec quelqu'un le temps passe
beaucoup plus vite que si je suis coincé
dans un embouteillage quand on est en
train de regarder une série ou que je
suis en train de scroller sur insta et
cetera les écrans siphonent notre
attention et donc siphonent le temps et
donc je pense que quand on a plus cette
attention complètement siphonnée par
l'utilisation des écrans le rapport au
temps va changer si je suis en train de
faire quelque chose je suis pas en train
de faire autre chose et donc en moyenne
disons selon les recherches on utilise 6
à 8 à 10h d'écran par jour bah ça ça va
être 6 à 8h 10h qu'il faut remplir
alle je fais quoi
moi non
[Musique]
sérieux
oh ça fait les plans comme dans les
recherches
marine disparu le 14 janvier à
saintalbert dans la petite ville de
montoise n'importe quoi en fait je
voulais juste vous dire que si en fait
on doit faire un mini bilan de tout
ça Jen fait le téléphone en fait gre le
téléphone il s'est trop incrusté dans la
société je sais pas si vous avez compris
maintenant tout se fait avec nos
téléphones la carte bleue elle y est sur
le téléphone genre le téléphone genre il
est trop lâche et là en fait le fait que
j'ai pas de téléphone je sais pas c'est
bizarre mais en fait c'est bien je sais
pas si vous avez compris style là je me
suis rendu compte que tout le monde mais
vraiment tout le monde sans exception
reste sur leur téléphone genre vraiment
H72 alors que moi la preuve j'ai ça que
ceux qui veulent m'appeler il
m'appellent c'est bien moi je vous dis
testez he ça va vous faire du bien dans
votre vie
euh bon je vais me faire une petite
session linddin recherche de taf parce
que si j'ai pu techniquement garder mon
ordi c'est un peu à cause de
ça je vais voir ce qu'il y a en ce
[Musique]
moment
ouis c'est quand même difficile parce
que mine de rien moi je suis là en fait
la journée vu que je suis en recherche
d'emploi donc j'ai beaucoup beaucoup
d'heur à combler et généralement je
comble ces heures là en faisant parfois
un peu de sport ou de la marche ou bien
mater une série tout simplement et là
les journées sont extrêmement
longues
[Musique]
ça vous a manqué de jouer depuis que
vous avez plus votre
téléphone paradoxalement non non pas
téléphone donc je jouais pas il jouit
beaucoup sur le téléphone en fait et
pour les réseaux sociaux c'était la même
chose là aussi de tout façon assez
inattendu vous par exemple vous
utiliseiez beaucoup Twitter il me semble
uniquement ouais non du coup ça me
manque vraiment ça manque pas vraiment
parce que là pour le coup en plus je
sais
pas en quo le jeu rubicbe tape ou pas
sur le système mais Twitter ça je sais
qu'il y a des moments je me je m'énerve
toute seule et je me dis que bon il y a
quelque chose qui va pas
[Musique]
quoi bon demain part à ven ça va leur
faire du bien de changer d'air même pas
imaginer à quel point il risque de
galérer le
écr instant du déballage du cadeau je
leuri préparé une petite
surprise
[Musique]
alors il est
beau la vie avant Instagram c'était ça
[Musique]
Instagram
alors on a pris des plans des cartes
donc là on va à la
[Musique]
recherche en fait as oublié de dire que
le plan il coûte 3 € ah oui c'est vrai
le plan éta payant sur mon iPhone il est
gratuit
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
le plan en fait il est pas interactif tu
touches il y a rien qui se passe
elle me dit que c'est à gauche je dis
que c'est à
droite voilà bon il est l'heure de me
confesser ça fait
exactement 5 minutes je crois qu'on
cherche le bus j'ai envie de de péter un
câble j'ai envie de péter un câble en
fait ça ça me stresse de pas avoir les
informations et c'est grave parce que
je je ne me connais pas comme ça je suis
quelqu'un beaucoup de très laissé aller
je me prends pas forcément la tête et en
fait je me rends compte que j'ai
peut-être développé un nouveau
comportement à cause de à cause des
écrans à cause de l'information
accessible limite de manière instantanée
genre là j'ai envie que ça aille vite
j'ai envie d'avoir l'information j'ai
envie de rentrer dans le bus arriver
vite gérer mes trucs vite vivre ma vie
vite vite voilà
vite l'écran a apporté une instantanéité
ouais je suis habitué à savoir quand
est-ce que le métro passe savoir dans
combien de minutes passe le bus pour
timer quand est-ce que je pars de chez
moi je suis habitué à pouvoir regarder
les reviews du turisto je veux manger
notre cerveau est un peu comparatif du
coup c'est cet effet de contraste j'ai
quelque chose et on me l'enlève bah je
suis pas
[Applaudissements]
content euh on a craqué on a craqué on a
craqué on a retéléchargé les
applications cap peur et compagnie mais
il faisait froid il faisait tard et en
fait à partir d'un moment fallait
calculer les distances savoir à quelle
heure on arrivit pour savoir si on
allait pouvoir manger ou pas parce qu'on
avait pas manger de la journée et on a
retéléchargé à la
fin bonjour Taric je souhaiterai
récupérer mon ordinateur peux-tu me le
rapporter
merci je lui rends r
pas franchement ça sent pas le texto
d'un gars qui veut juste zonner sur
facebook merci c'est gentil de me le
rendre pourquoi vous en avez besoin
c'est pas le travail puisque je je ne
travaille plus je suis retraité enfin
c'est pour mes activités voilà
bénévol bonjour mal bonjour tout le
monde en fait
pour tout dire je suis en train de
participer à une expérience qui un mois
sans
oh wou j'avais déjà fait ça il y a 35
ans mais c'était privé de télé ça
s'appelait et qu'est-ce que vous avez
appris sur votre
couple on me divorce pas au bout d'un
mois s télé non ben c'est pas du tout la
même chose privée de télé privée d'écran
hein mon avis aujourd'hui c'est
vachement dur si tu veux bon on a été
prévenu donc tu peux d'abord on a
accepté puis on a été prévenu donc on
peut préparer mais tu penses absolument
pas à tout à toutes les conséquences
quotidien de
ça bref aujourd'hui on va faire un
concours de référence OK ou
[Musique]
pas Lou Lou tu vas où là ah non je suis
là t'inquiète parce que je courrais tout
loup loup voilà c'est ça
Magalie Magalie qu'est-ce que tu fais
mag qu'est-ce que tu fais
Magalie
Magalie principalement celle-là en fait
je voulais la faire pour le bruit du
silence en fait sans écran
on en tout cas moi j'ai l'impression
d'être en paix
bien sûr ça dépend hier j'ai envie de
pter un ça me stresse en fait là je suis
stressé j'étais grave en stress mais là
pour le coup j'ai l'impression de
ressentir un petit peu de
paix de pas avoir le stress de recevoir
une
notification d'être dans
[Musique]
l'instant la veille il faut que ça aille
vite parce que il y a un but qu'on veut
atteindre qui est trouver mon hôtel
pouvoir manger être chaud on appelle ça
des comportements orientés vers un
but le lendemain il dit je suis content
que ça aille lentement parce que
probablement s'il avait son téléphone il
aurait eu des comportements non orientés
vers un but il serait en train de
scroller par remplissage par habitude
donc c'est là le paradoxe et là on
revient à l'usage du téléphone oui fin
des années 90 début des années 2000 on
faisait beaucoup de recherche sur le
temps d'écran mais depuis il y a une
sorte de de changement de paradigme
aujourd'hui on parle de qu'est-ce qu'on
fait sur
l'écran C cose gratis
[Musique]
quasi da qui puoi vedere la Giudecca e
San
Giorgio sur son téléphone c'est B tout
me est en mode smartOne
[Musique]
part
donc là on est on est en plein dans le
centre-ville de
Vénise vu qu'on on a le polaroïde on a
pris quelques clichés il pas ils sont
pas super
réussis les PaaS de l'époque il ne
mettent pas notre carnation en
valeur 1 2
Ren rien qui est sorti oh là là mais il
en restait pas là je crois qu' en
a voilà ça ça ça n'arrive pas ça ça
n'arrive pas avec les
[Musique]
écrans a réutilisé le PO on a demandé à
des gens justement de nous prendre en
photo après quelques minutes de suspense
on va voir le résultat déjà je te la
montre pour que tu
vois alors je tiens à dire qu'on a été
pris par une photographe en formation
internationale de ce que de ce que j'ai
de ce qu'on a pu comprendre on nous a
dit que c'était une excellente
photographe et elle avait un appareil
photo sur elle voici le cliché qu'elle a
pris de
nous voilà on peut voir deux ombres ici
cher et moi ça c'est censé être je sais
plus comment ça s'appelle là mais bon ça
reprem bien la place sa marque et puis
voilà quoi je pense qu'on va finir par
garder nos téléphone oui parce que là la
qualité d'iPhone me manque ça devient
[Musique]
grave 3è semaine comment ça va ça va ça
va commence être un peu long tout de
même le reconnaître moi je pense oui oui
ça manque de
réseau récupérer sa voiture et réparer
sa voiture je ce qui est intéressant
c'est que s'en fout de la télé
ouais la
télé je m'ennu c'est
compliquéirécqu pourquoi par que quand
tuas paséc tu t' tuas vraiment rien à
[Musique]
faire
après que j'ai fini ma journée ménage en
fait j'avais tellement tout donné que je
me suis octroyé à un moment où j'ai dit
non en fait tu vas regarder un épisode
d'une série en fait parce que tu le
mérites c'est là où effectivement je me
rends compte de ce rapport là
avec avec les écrans quoi parce que
j'avais besoin de ce moment-là pour
vraiment redescendre et me reposer entre
guillemets à travers une série
hello tar comment ça va alors je te fais
cette vidéo en gage d'n parce que voil
aujourd'hui je suis allé sur
insts comme tu sais parce que je
travaille du coup avec des étudiants et
on fait pas mal d'activités ou d'action
sur Instagram il y a pas mal d'émissions
qui sont axé sur ça et en fait en allant
sur
insta un moment mon
compte voilà mon compte s'est affiché
comme tu peux le voir et puis je me suis
retrouvé dans ce genre de vidéo à liker
des
hippopotames j'ai craqué c'était pas de
la faiblesse c'était pas volontaire très
sincèrement donc voilà il est au travail
il a le droit à son écran il travaille
sur insta ou il glisse qu'est-ce qu' j
fait exprès ouais habitudes des
habitudes et peut-être un peu de
mauvaise foi je connais pas je suis
désolé tu regarde ça mais sil y a un
message pour moi qui est très important
c'est que très peu de choses sont juste
une question de volonté individuelle
c'est une sorte de myth ça ça fait
consensus avec les les gens qui qui sont
dans ton milieu ah oui oui oui bien sûr
c'est par exemple en thérapist moi je
suis psychologue si Ctait juste un truc
de de volonté quelqu'un de déprimé je
lui dis bah sois plus content sa imagine
tu viens en thérapie chez ton PS tu dit
je suis triste tu lu dis en fait tu as
qu'à décider volontairement d'être plus
content dit ok merci c'est fini la
ça marche pas comme
ça viens là pas voirre non il est
actuellement 18h2 on est sorti pour
aller jouer au basket là derrière est
stade
voilà personne chez nous éta tout seule
on s'ennuyait on est
sorti
dis Siri il y a quoi à la télé ce soir
ce soir à la télé il y a
[Musique]
Kanta j'ai trouvé le
trésor nonas qure cartes à prendre mais
c'est un plus de à quoi tu as qure
cartes à prendre tu as qure cartes à
prendre mais c'est un+ 2 à
quoi et la desessence de piocher six
cartes depuis tout à l'heure tu vend et
j'apprécie pas je t'ai le truc il a 13
ans tu as de la chance il y a pas
YouTube tout de suite je
[Musique]
m'ich
tu as oublié qu' avit colanta ce soir
franchement quand même pas moi j'ai
grave
zapper
on reçoit plein de messages sur colanta
depuis tout à
l'heure ça a l'air d'être the
épisode on m dit c'est un truc
deou donc on va craquer on va le
regarder je tiens à dire que
la pression c'est pas
vrai c'est pas vra c'est
mutuel leur famille le envoie des text
ouais pour leur dire vous êtes en train
de rater un épisode de ouf on crée des
groupes sociaux il y a des normes dans
ces groupes sociaux des habitudes un
langage commun des expressions des
centres d'intérêt commun donc leur
famille leur dire en fait vous avez pas
le droit d'être privé d'écran parce que
c'est en train de nous priver
d'interaction avec vous un objet commun
qu'on a ensemble qui est cet épisode de
colanta et ça c'est là où on voit que
c'est pas l'écran c'est l'imbrication
dans la vie sociale
ouais bon là ça a triché dans tous les
sens clairement Parina Celina mais bon
elles font qu'une semaine d'expérience
c'est peut-être un petit peu plus facile
fallait s'y attendre en même temps un
mois c'est long quoi euh on va voir
comment ça se passe il reste plus que 4
jours avant que je ramène les
écrans ils ont caché le
U en même temps c'est bien que vous
voyez un peu ce qu'on souffre
he je me suis aperçu que et ben il y a
des SMS que je ne reçois pas parce que
ne fonctionne oui ne fonctionne que la
fonction SMS et pas SMS et pas iMessage
je vais me fâcher avec des gens je sais
que je suis fâché là aujourd'hui avec
des gens mais que je ne connais
pas parce que ils m'ont sans doute
demandé de les rappeler ou des choses
comme ça et j'ai j'ai pas fait derrière
bon voilà éner général par le
truc au moins une soirée sans écran oui
alors mettez vos téléphones dans la
boîte non rigole attends j'envoie mes
derniers
tau ma chérie ton téléphone est derrière
toi je vois que tu le cherches
voilà tu veux que je t'aide des
enfants
mais tu sais en plus c'est même pas il
mange même samedi nous avons fait une
soirée jeu avec des invités et on a
décidé à la dernière minute de
confisquer tout leur téléphones pendant
la soirée jeu et de les mettre dans une
boîte et ils étaient tous super
perturbés quoi il va
tenir il est il est mort on
Vauper on va s'occuper on va jouer on va
jouer merci ça c'est moi ça c'est moi je
sais que c'est moi ça donc sevrage on va
t'aider il a dit imagine il y a un truc
important sur qui se passe là dans ta
famille ou un truc comme ça mais tu le
sauras après le monde il continue
tour à un moment donné là c'est de la
dicte pur et dur non mais une fois tu te
dis j'ai
essayé laiss PP mais ça fait que 2
minutes tu as pas de téléphone mais je
suis arrivé j'ai vu il y a pas de télé
il y a pas de truc mais
lui c'est pas
possible clairement genre le smartphone
il peut déglinguer mon cerveau tuas
dépend comment tu définis déglinguer
est-ce que tu vas te retrouver malade
avec ton smartphone encore une fois
qu'est-ce que pourquoi tu l'utilises si
tu deviens monotach et tu joues à C
crash 8h par jour ça va ça va appauvrir
tes relations sociales ça va appauvrir
ton attention ça va appauvrir ta
diversification mais c'est comme si tu
passes ta journée à je sais pas à lire
le même livre à répétition ça va
déglinguer le cerveau de la
manière pourquoi tu utilises si jeux
t'expliquer la bataille de je sais pas
moi de Marignan en 15 15 dans un livre
d'histoire versus te montrer
une des acteurs qui sont en train de la
rejouer avec une analyse stratégique un
peu à la Game of Thrones du truc
peut-être que ça va te marquer plus
pourquoi tu l'utilises est-ce que ça
peut te déglinguer tout peut te
déglinguer le cerveau
genre Joker mais pour quelques
instants en
premier le plus accro le plus accro
tiens il est sur insta
Lesur il est sur
snap on est en train de faire une soirée
làit on cache no téléphone ici et
personne n le droit de
l'utiliser un drogé et moi je suis un
drogué oui j'ass alors en général est là
c'est lui mon bourreau moi je
général et est-ce que tu as ressenti un
manque un grand manque un manque sur une
échelle de 1 à 10 je suis à 15 à 15
ouais est-ce que ça a changé ta façon de
te comporter avec tes amis ça non pas du
tout parce que eux ils ont leur
téléphone c'est moi je l'ai regardéis et
je leur disais ouais vous pouvez pas
poser vot téléphone un peu un peu de
solidarité après moi dit non ça c'est
du coup voilà et du coup tu trouves que
c'est un vrai problème de ne pas avoir
son téléphone sur soi oui est-ce que
quand on est ados c'est plus facile de
créer des nouvelles habitudes
théoriquement c'est plus facile de créer
des nouvelles habitudes pratiquement ça
dépend si mes potes sont en train de
créer ces nouvelles habitudes avec moi
ouais sinon je me retrouve seul était
seul Ines bah elle était seul Ines et si
Ines doit être seulle pendant toute
l'année scolaire au bout d'un moment ça
va être très très compliqué pour elle ça
va peut-être avoir même un impact
négatif sur sa santé mentale plus que si
elle avait son écran à nouveau c'est
peut-être pour ça que fait qu'une
semaine
voilà redis-moi ce que tu m'as dit là il
y a 5
minutes j'ai récér
elle en peut plus elle veut craquer va
lire un livre non va lire un livre j'ai
pas d'humeur bah va écrire dans ton
cahier alors je écrire je vais récupérer
ma s non tu vas écrire tes humeurs
comment tu te sens malheureuse en
dépression
it's back c'est la NRE celle W
voil manqué vraiment beaucoup énormément
ah ouais ouis vous allez la remettre là
bah on réfléchit on réfléchit justement
on est en train de parce qu'il y du
changement là déjà sur la la
dispo our dans la vie réelle c'est ça
ouais enfin je sais pas virtuel non
c'est un écran malgré
tout message oui c'est tout list c'est
45 non mais on va passer une semaine à
les à les consulter on va vous maudir ah
ouais tu pars un mois tu reviens c'est
ouf quand même il a 5
ans
waouh là on va devoir rattraper tout
çaul j'ai oublié le téléphone ah non non
non non non c'est pas possible le
téléphone pour de vrai
ouais non pour de
vrai je les ai mis dans un autre sac
end je ss sont pas là quand même ah moi
j'ai sû moi j'en ai rêvé de mon
téléphone moi ça me dérange pas j'ai la
switch ça me va c'est pas ce
téléphone tu pourrais tenir combien de
temps encore ah je pourrais pas tenir ça
là non il est là je peux plus me le voir
non mais vraiment moi je le veux
[Musique]
vous pouvez le
garder l'écran le tacle mais là il y a
un écran mais le
tactile personnellement je suis très
satisfaite et le fait d'avoir été privé
d'écranah ça m'a encore plus aidé à me
découvrir à savoir ce qui me plaît ce
qui m'anime ce qui me fait vibrer
changer mes mauvaises habitudes les
choses sur lesquelles je perds
énormément de temps après c'est bien que
ce soit fini un mois c'est bien plus je
pense que j'aurais pu craquer mais là je
pense que c'était bon là côté timing
c'est parfait là toi cher c'est grave ce
que je vais dire parce que ça se trouve
que je vais pas tenir mais là à
l'instant T aujourd'hui je me dis insta
je vais pas le retélécharger c'est ce
que j'allais dire moi je pense que je
vais le supprimer parce que je préfère y
aller de temps en temps sur Safari et
regarder ce que j'ai regardé et
ressortir plutôt que d'être tout le
temps sur l'application la petite
addiction enfin c'est même pas une
addiction ENF une habitude c'est de
regarder et et de s'énerver toute seule
sur Twitter et là je me rends compte que
c'est très apaisant en fait et non je je
suis presque sûr que je vais retirer
Twitter et ce qui est en fait apaisant
moi je trouve pour moi c'est
que c'est ne pas se contraindre soi-même
à être un peu en permanence à consulter
ce qui se
dit parce qu'en fait au fond on s'en
fout en fait voilà quand on arrête on
s'aperçoit qu'on s'en fout complètement
et tu vas changer des habitudes ou pas
oui lesquels tu vas l'utiliser comment
maintenant le T comment euh moins
attends comment on dit moins plus
qu'avant moins plus qu'avant moins
qu'avant c'est mieux moins
qu'avant
non c'est bon j'arrive j'arrive j'arrive
changer j'arrive c'est intéressant de
l'avoir fait et avoir pris conscience
par qu' le disent explicitement tout le
monde explicitement ça nous a fait du
bien
c'était ch ch bien de voir que ça
changeitme 10 minutes que vous êtes
par
[Musique]
comment ça va depuis le retour des écran
faut jamais promettre des choses quand
on est
content je me suis dit je suis un nouvel
homme je suis
purifié je l'ai clairement
téléchargé je suis clairement actif
DESS
on a repris nos soiré télé
évidemment on a rattrapé notre retard
sur de TR
[Musique]
séries on
retrouve notre vie d'avant mais de
manière un petit peu plus consciente et
exactement c'est leç de vie maintenant
on réalise plus on est plus dans
l'instant présent c'est par exemple on a
envie de regarder la télé ou que ça n
saoule on va dire bon on pas tandis
qu'avant elle aurait pu être là pendant
des heures et des heures sans télé on
sait qu'on pourrait M S télé
aujourd'hui moi j'ai une annonce à faire
euh j'ai radié Twitter j'ai viré lappli
et et je m'en pr de
[Musique]
bien